اصحابه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فوق الاخرى ارتدى نظارته السوداء امسك يد
ابنته وبضغطه زر واحده ارغب الجيران ليضع
الامريكان ايديهم على صدورهم
فاي سلاح هذا مهلا مهلا عاد المجنون ليعبر
عن جنونه بسلاح اخر بضربه واحده ينهي
الحياه في ولايه كامله ليوعيدها الى العصر
الحجري يا لقسوته جهاز التحكمه مليء
بالاسلحه يكفي ان يضع اصبعه على الزر
الخاص باي سلاح يختاره عندها سيظهر العجب
العجاب انها اسلحه اعادت الولايات المتحده
الى التفاوض بعد ان هددت باستخدام القوه
فعن اي رغب نتحدث نعم عن اسلحه كوريا
الشماليه التي ارعبت امريكا نتحدث وللقصه
بقيه لما اخافت قوانين كيم جون جون الداخل
ارعبت اسلحته الخارج وبين الداخل والخارج
نشر المجنون الرعب باسلحته المجنونه وها
هو كم يطلق صاروخا وصف بانه الاقوى في
العالم يطلق من الغواصات
[موسيقى]
وهو صاروخ الذي اعطى دليلا دامغا على قوه
جيش كوريا الشماليه المرعب الصاروخ الذي
قال عنه المراقبون ان احدا لم يره من قبل
هذا الصاروخ هو رساله للولايات المتحده
بشان الخبره العسكريه التي تتمتع بها
كوريا الشماليه تحت اشراف الزعيم كيم جونغ
اون
القنبله الهيدروجينيه عام 2017 اصابت
كوريا الشماليه العالم كله بالرعب حين
اعلنت النجاح في صنع القنبله الهيدروجينيه
الخاصه بها اجرت عليها اختبارا لينتج عن
ذلك هزات ارضيه مخيفه وصلت الى كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان بل سمعتم بها من قبل ان
كنتم سمعتم بها فقد اعلنت كوريا الشماليه
انه يمكن تحميل هذه القنبله على صواريخها
البالستيه العابره للقارات فما هي هذه
القنبله
القنبله الهيدروجينيه ذات قدره تدميريه
اكبر بكثير من القنبله النوويه التي تعتمد
على مبدا انشطار ذرات
الهيدروجينيه يتم فيها تفجير على مرحله
مرحلتين الاولى تفجير نووي صغير للمساعده
في تفجير النووي اخر اكثر قوه بكثير ناجم
عن اتحاد الذرات وليس انشطارها حيث ان
القنبله النوويه يظل تاثيرها الاشعاعي
لسنوات عديده اما نظيرتها الهيدروجينيه
فانها تدمر كل شيء في ثوان معدوده وليس لا
تاثير اشعاعي ممتد اي انها تحيل كل شيء
حولها الى الخراب ولا تذر شيئا على قيد
الحياه انها اباده للحياه يا ساده تطلق
عليها القاب اخرى مثل القنبله الحراريه او
القنبله الاندماجيه
[موسيقى]
الصاروخ الوحشي
صواريخ كم هي اكثر اسلحته قوه ليس على
المستوى المحلي فقط بل على المستوى
العالمي
12 صاروخ يبلغ مدى اربعه الاف وخمسمائه
التي تكفي لضرب قاعده جوام الامريكيه
انطلاقا من كوريا الشماليه جاء بعده
الذي يصل مداه الى عشره الاف كيلو متر
وبهذا المدى يمكن للصاروخ ان يجعلن
نيويورك في مرمى اهدافه لتفصل بينه 14
وبين الولايات الامريكيه ضغطه زر من
المجنون فقط لياتي بعده هوسونج خمسه عشر
والذي يبلغ مدى 14 الف كيلو متر ما يضع
كامل القاره الامريكيه نصب عينيه كل هذه
الصواريخ الكوريه عابره للقارات وهنا يظهر
زعيم هذه الصواريخ اكثرها رعبا نعم انه
صاروخ اهواز 17
الذي يقدر على حمل عده رؤوس حربيه ونوويه
ما يجعل من الصعب على الدوله ما الدفاع عن
نفسها امامها بمدن يصل الى 15 الف كيلو
متر او اكثر
كتفت من تجارب هذا الصاروخ منذ بدء الحرب
الاوكرانيه ازيح السيتار لاول مره عنه
بالصاروخ الوحشي وهو اكبر صاروخ باليسلي
كوري شمالي عام 2020 والعالم باسره اصبح
في مرمى اهداف كينج من الشرق الى الغرب
ومن الشباب الى الجنوب فماذا بعد يا حفيده
ال سونج
النبضه المغناطيسيه
انها القنبله
الكهرومغناطيسيه ياساده يا قنبله
الكترونيه وهي السلاح الذي يهدف الى تعطيل
الاجهزه الالكترونيه من خلال النبضه
المغناطيسيه الكهربائيه الكبرى التي
يمكنها التداخل مع الاجهزه الكهربائيه
والالكترونيه ونظم تشغيلها لالحاق اضرار
فيها واتلافها يمكن لهذه القنبله ان تعيد
مدينه باكملها مئات سنوات الى الوراء تقضي
على الكهرباء والاجهزه الالكترونيه ما
يعني العوده الى القلم والرقعه والسيف
والحصان كل ذلك بضغطه زر واحد من كيم جونغ
فماذا لو ضغط على العديد من الازرار
المشابهه ليصبح مصير العالم مرهونا تحت
اصبعكم الولايات المتحده هي العدو الاول
لكم لذلك على الامريكيين ان يخافوا من هذه
القنبله تحدي فان قرر كم يوما القاء
القنبله الكيرومغناطيسيه على الاراضي
الامريكيه هناك ستغلق شبكه الكهرباء
الامريكيه لفتره غير محدده ما سيؤدي الى
حالات وفاه خلال عام واحد تصل الى 90% من
جميع الامريكيين لكن ما يزيد الطين بيله
على امريكا هو ان هذه النبضه المغناطيسيه
لا يتوجب القاؤها على المدينه التي يريد
تدميرها كالقنابل النوويه ويكفي ان يتم
تفجيرها على ارتفاع مئات الاميال لتوقف
الطاقه الكهربائيه بالكامل في الولايات
المتحده عندها سيكون العالم كانت هنا مدن
امريكيه ولكنها محيت بمنخارج